[Music]
soldiers preventing protesters from
taking over an airport using deadly
force several people were killed on
Thursday and more than 50 wounded in the
southern Andean city of ayakucho human
rights groups say soldiers shot at
demonstrators with live rounds
people were walking with stones or other
objects in their hands but they were
only stones or a sign and in response
soldiers shot them this is extrajudicial
killings this is murder
[Music]
the Army says the soldiers came under
attack and responded the conflict is
escalating perusing a state of emergency
the Ministers of education and culture
have resigned and protesters are
demanding new elections
but on Friday lawmakers failed to reach
87 votes needed to bring the elections
forward the protesters main demand the
mayor of ayakucho is angry
we cannot allow the Congress to be out
of tune with its own population in the
midst of a crisis where we are bleeding
to death
the capital Lima has been fortified and
thousands of police have been deployed
not all the protesters have been violent
on Friday police didn't fight these
demonstrators instead escorted them as
they marched peacefully
after nine days of social unrest while
ter Mendoza remembers how his indigenous
ashanika Community suffered during the
armed conflict more than 30 years ago on
Friday he marched for peace
we are here because our asheninka
brothers died and now we don't want
violence
peruvians who say they're fed up with
the violence not only from now but from
a history of an armed conflict in the
80s and 90s that left more than 60 000
peruvians dead that's why these
peruvians are saying they want peace now
ayakucho is one of the 15 regions under
curfew it was at the center of the
violence during the 80s and again now
president Dina boluarte has called on
Governors and church leaders to join
government officials and begin dialogue
with leaders of the most conflicted
areas but boluarte has also said she
supports the police and the Armed Forces
Lima Peru